but it I just can't believe these shows
like I didn't even know certain things
and when I did it kalila you turn on a
TV and it's like at a certain channel
you don't know exists like that one
about the Real Housewives of Orange
County
yeah yeah I look I like to watch great
things and I love to watch garbage
things it's when just garbage it's like
what is the point of that you're
watching a bunch of older white lady
rich who cares and they're like at a
diner and they're arguing agent each
other I don't give a [ __ ] it's like
we're a schmuck yeah Betty I'll there's
nothing I won't watch I'll watch
everything and anything just out of this
year curiosity I mean you have guilty
pleasures you showed me what you've gone
to talent agencies and watch demo reels
of young actor yeah we talked about yeah
but that's not that's funny though
nobody it's funny yeah you know I watch
people's reels and I go you know I don't
that's for fun right yeah
it's like when you watch failed hip-hop
artists artists or you know me you just
watched any kind of failing things on
YouTube oh yeah we do it through when
somebody trips you do gonna laugh in
their [ __ ] faces okay right but her
thing is she's being a voyeur and
watching a bunch of people and in their
into their lives that why would you even
give a [ __ ] like I don't care there
first of all can I just say this and
this is what I want to say this is a
fact all right having a personality
isn't a talent do you know why everybody
has a personality hmm you know how they
go oh he's a TV personality oh really
so he's like everyone else he just got
lucky what are you talking about how's
the Kardashians Talent there's no talent
there this is a bunch of people that got
lucky and a bunch of morons watch them
and then all of a sudden they're
franchises that are worth millions of
dollars and then guys like me look at it
and go wow that is an absolute crazy
thing mm-hmm it is crazy but you can't I
don't know you can't
knock the idea that let's suppose they
did get lucky right let's suppose her
sex tape is what catapulted her into the
was gigantic
you know fame that she's living in
regardless even if it's just luck alone
I can't hate on that luck it happened to
her she's making the money and lo and
behold the whole world cares and watches
and she's clickbait so it's like but I I
like to see it from the I'm intrigued by
the human condition of obsession of that
type of what we consider no talent I
mean yes you do consider it no talent
but there is there still and there's
obviously something to it that people
latch onto and I want to know what it is
because maybe I'll get into it do
reality show no I'm just saying watch it
so sell me what I'm supposed to latch on
to I mean for girls say for instance the
Kardashians they're all pretty girls
from baby okay though I want to see this
they're all a try okay
Jeremy alright but they're not the
hottest I so yeah when people say oh but
they're hot
they're they're pretty hot yeah there
are New York eight LA sevens sweetie odd
they're gorgeous girl no sweetie
if I've seen them before in real life
but by the way I know we both yeah
alright so that's number one
no I've seen all of them at one point of
my life of my and I have seen them with
my own eyeballs okay yeah trust me when
I say they're New York eight all right
they're not New York nines New York ten
those are like you know I mean like
husbands would maybe consider cheating
on their wives for right they're not
that okay that's number one so it's not
their hotness number two what is it
because they're Arminian see our menu
yeah did that have something to do with
it I want to figure out why I should be
watching it living vicariously through
someone else's life it's like why people
watch our vlogs no because I'll tell you
why because our vlogs or comedy it's for
upper them sometimes it's just us doing
nothing
yeah but it's not [ __ ] first of all
we don't make any money for ya right
we're not we don't we're not coca-cola
like the [ __ ] Kardashians are right
yeah it's it's like if people are
watching our vlog and we get 90 billion
[ __ ] views and all of a sudden like we
were in gigantic mansions I would feel
kind of guilty about it like what no I
don't want to be known for doing that
we'll see all of them have now launched
clothing lines makeup lines that's
because they're [ __ ] Fame they did it
and that's because we have more first of
all people voted for Trump these people
he's a blatant racist okay and people
for some what I'm saying is is that I I
guess I understand why people watch it
because we have a lot of people in the
world there are [ __ ] morons you know
they are like movies yeah yeah I saw
whatever some stupid movie yeah but
they've never seen great movies they're
idiots but I don't mind it yet I don't
mind that there is you want to get hit
in the jaw never happen I would never
ever never happen even if let me suss up
even if I did what the [ __ ] are you
gonna do about it
oh you all my do my name is Fred I heard
a hit yeah I'm sorry I gotta look
aggressive okay I don't think that
everyone has to be at the same level of
intelligence or aptitude I'm okay with
you know having Steven Avery's like just
because you don't have the capabilities
to [ __ ] read or to listen to [ __ ]
Tchaikovsky doesn't mean you're not you
know allowed to breathe on this planet
there you have every right to live and
that's not what I'm living but what I'm
saying it's beyond that it's just you
have every right to do anything that I
do you have a right to have your own
opinions you have every right to behave
in any kind of way unless it hurts other
people that's not what I'm saying we're
all snowflakes
for all human beings and we're all equal
okay
what I'm saying is that the reason why
we have chunk on television and in
movies etc etc is because we have a lot
of retards than living in the world okay
that's all I'm saying
okay especially if you're a girl and
you're watching the Kardashians
that's one thing because maybe you can
learn maybe if there was a show about a
bunch of guys that wore raw denim and
I'm like all kind of brown around am I
looking white wear that watch that yeah
yeah I mean hair color my passion right
so I get why girls or gay people if a
gay guys like I like what you know mean
whatever that was a bad impression but
yeah if you're a heterosexual dude and
you like that show you you you just
don't say hi to me geez okay
don't go anywhere near me you hear that
no you're not